j'ai fini par l'avoir la médaille après
dans un ch et celle des de saint jérôme
sylvie fréchette fait campagne à sa
façon elle passe 5 à 10 minutes à
discuter avec chaque électeur qu'elle
rencontre qu'est ce que vous avez fait
un commerce de quoi que vous aviez vous
ces deux belles phone c'est l'homme en
affaires mais j'aime ce l'être humain
qui est le il m'a appris on a échangé on
a eu du plaisir c'est moi la politique
pour moi c'est un c'est un bonus de dire
maintenant qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour ces gens là que j'apprends sauf que
l'ancienne nageuse olympique a beau être
connu et apprécié dans rivière du nord
on sent que sa médaille de député sera
difficile à gagner
la stratégie conservatrice de présenter
un candidat vedette qui a si bien marché
dans chicoutimi le fjord avec l'ex
entraîneur doc et richard martel semble
ici se heurter au regain de vie du bloc
québécois
pour le moment je pense que mon
s'approche plus 20 blocs si ces
québécois la langue française est
importante
tu serais là une belle approche mais en
même temps faut voter pour le parti
aussi non non et pourquoi
ben c'est sûr c'est l'état du parti
l'avortement puis c'est pas pour ça oui
je me fais dire beaucoup mais moi je
change pas qui je suis ce que j'apprécie
c'est que j'ai un chef qui payent peu de
cryptes c'est lui y est pas à l'aise lui
c'est un pro vie moi je suis une pro
choix mais ce que ça veut dire qui est
pas capable de gérer un pays
bonjour bon retour merci le député
sortant le bloquiste réal forte semble
donc avoir une longueur d'avancé dans
cette circonscription souverainiste je
sein de l' enthousiasme chez les
électeurs qui voit de bonneuil d'un bloc
québécois ragaillardi qui fait les 20 et
30 députés à ottawa on s'en contente du
statut de parti d'opposition non
seulement s'en contente mais aussi
complet parce que nous on off porte pour
tâche pour mandat de bien représenter
des électeurs du québec bonne personne
en quittant la gare il rencontre son
adversaire néo-démocrate le comté a été
emporté par la vague orange en 2011 et
le npd a terminé à 1000 voix seulement
du bloc il y a quatre ans les temps ont
changé myriam ouellette est devenue
candidate alors que la campagne était
déjà commencé elle n'a pas encore de
pancarte je regarde plus une tranche
d'âge un peu plus jeune je voudrais
l'eau autour de l'âtre internet 20 40 1
les changements climatiques sont la clé
npd on a une plateforme
merci de votre belle énergie qu'on
continue à travailler sur le terrain
jeune consultante en affaires publiques
la candidate libérale florence gagnon
elle rappelle que les libéraux n'ont pas
fini très loin du bloc que non plus en
2015 pour convaincre ennemis sur les
chances de son parti de prendre le
pouvoir
on n'est pas loin derrière puis je pense
que c'est ici une circonscription qu'on
peut avoir
- député ici mais ce soit que je peux
aller chercher plus des 2 au niveau du
gouvernement à ottawa
le défi s'annonce donc difficile pour
sylvie fréchette qui quoi qu'il arrive
le 21 octobre ne regrette rien de son
entrée en politique c'est son nouveau
sport ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio
canada saint-girons